(audience applauds)
- I love your top,
it's so cute.
- I love your style.
It's a onesie.
- Oh, is it?
- I love
a onesie.
- Oh, that's amazing.
- I never grew out of it from childhood,
so wait, for everybody
that hasn't seen the show,
I've seen it tons, we
love it at our house,
but explain to everybody what it is
'cause it's animated and live action.
- Yeah, it is, it's awesome.
So it's a kid show,
obviously.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it follows my character Gabby.
And it starts off in
her real life bedroom.
And she gets this dollhouse delivery
and it comes down a slide
and inside is a surprise
that'll kind of show where
the adventure's gonna take her
and all her friends for the day.
- Yeah.
- And then she does,
as you just saw in the clip,
this special pinch pinch song
that transforms her into an animation.
And she gets to go inside of
her dollhouse as an animation
and play with all her Gabby cats
where they do crafts and sing songs
and just learn all kinds of great things.
Look, I'm 41 and like I watch it too.
(audience laughs)
Because, you know, you
watch 'em with your kids
and I just, I get lost in it,
and then all of a sudden I'll
notice they've left the room
and I'm like, why am I still sitting here?
But it's like, it's very captivating.
- Yeah.
- This is,
I hear though your first,
is this your first time on a talk show?
- Yeah.
- First time?
Oh my God.
(crowd applauds)
My kids love this show.
I just figured you've done
promo for it everywhere,
yeah, that's amazing.
- Well, it was a little weird
'cause a lot of the time
it was during COVID,
so it was mostly
- [Kelly] Oh, that's right.
- like Zoom interviews,
which,
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- is not the same thing
as this.
- It's really not
the same thing.
- Yeah.
- I had to interview
Cher for the first time
with COVID from home and I was like,
Satan is winning today, yeah,
yeah.
- Exactly.
- We wanted to find out what
questions kids might have
for Laila, so we asked around.
It turns out a lot of them
want to know one very specific
thing, so let's take a look.
- Can you show me how to
shrink down in the dollhouse
just like you?
- Did you have workers make that,
like make yourself into a little doll
or did you like shrink yourself somehow?
- How do you shrink?
Yay!
- Alright.
(audience applauds)
- What is your answer?
I'm sure you've been asked this.
- I have, I've gotten
asked this a few times
and.
- It's a tricky question.
- Don't break the wall.
- The big reveal is I
do my pinch pinch dance
and I grab Pandy's hand and magic,
magic shrinks me and I
go into the dollhouse.
That's the big answer.
It's just magic.
- Yeah,
I love magic.
Well, we have the creator
of Gabby's Dollhouse
in the audience.
Everybody say hello to
Traci Paige Johnson.
What's up Tracy?
(audience applauds)
So when did you know creating this,
'cause I'm sure you have
an idea in your head,
like, when did you know
that Laila was Gabby?
- Oh, we saw thousands of
girls and we knew immediately.
Quick shout out to my
co-creator Jen Twomey
who couldn't be here.
Jen, we love you!
(audience applauds)
- We just knew Laila.
I mean, you can see her genuine energy,
that connection to camera,
and just, you have the,
you are the epitome of growth mindset
and celebrating your
mistakes and, you know,
just such a great role model for girls
and boys
- You do have a certain light
about you.
- everywhere.
And she has a special magic
trick with her eyebrows.
She's very expressive
with her eyebrows.
- Very, very
expressive eyebrows.
- People would pay for those eyebrows.
Those are nice eyebrows.
- She comes in and like looking at camera,
I mean, all kids are just
ahhh, perfect play date,
so she, we knew immediately.
- How does it feel to be a part
of kids' lives in that way?
That's kind of cool.
- It's just so unreal and it
just, it makes me so happy,
and like, 'cause there's so many ways,
like not only 'cause they've,
like, kids have experienced
a lot of instability
these past years.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And to be like a part of the show
that like teaches resilience
and like, you know,
you can be like a source
of stability for them,
that's amazing.
And also just knowing,
like when I was a kid,
like growing up, I
didn't see too many girls
that looked like me on the
screen, like whatever shows
I was watching.
- Yeah.
- The fact that I can like
be that like sense of like,
oh my gosh, she looks like me.
- Yeah.
- It's just, it's so amazing
and I, it just, I'm so
grateful that I could do that
and I am proud of that that
I get to be that for kids.
- You also have such a cool
job for a high school student.
- Right.
- Yeah.
Well, Gabby's Dollhouse
isn't just a TV series.
Gabby's Dollhouse toys from Spin Master
bring the imaginative
dollhouse world to life
with music, surprises, and magic
for kids to create their own adventures,
this is why my kids love it,
and we're sending everyone home
with the award-winning
Gabby's Purrfect Dollhouse,
Kitty Fairy's Garden Treehouse,
and the newest playset,
the (indistinct).
(audience cheers)
Every single playset connects
back to the dollhouse.
Plus, thanks to our friends at DreamWorks,
you're also getting a
$150.00 Walmart gift card
to build out your Gabby's
Dollhouse world with fashion,
bedding, party decor, and more.
Everybody, you can check out
Dreamworks animation series
"Gabby's Dollhouse" on Netflix.